it is one of the most iconic bars in las
vegas and they're always giving back to
the community and joining me now from
the golden tiki is beverage director
adam reigns welcome hello i'm so happy
to be here you look so festive i love
the outfit it's all about the golden
tiki and you've got the ensemble going
on here thank you you have to keep it
fun you got to keep it fine it really is
about fun and the golden tiki is iconic
and you guys are doing something really
cool tell us a little bit about this
program that you guys have going on
absolutely i'm really happy that we can
bring it back
it's it's our charity cocktail charity
mug program so every month we'll
partner with a different
uh spirit brand and a different charity
and we'll sell a cocktail and a mug
all month and proceeds will go to part
of the proceeds go to a charity this
month we're doing a nevada partnership
for homeless youth oh that's wonderful
what a great organization and so if you
go in in the next few days before the
end of the month what can people get
so well for july we're doing a cocktail
called trespuntos okay
yes can we make this i'm set up i'm
ready to go
i'll be your bar back here tell me what
you need beautiful awesome awesome so
the tres puntos is a uh agave spirits
based tropical cocktail because i think
that agave spirits tequila and mezcals
have a really
great place and should be in tropical
cocktails i love that i love that idea
so tell me what you need here so let's
let's start with the lime juice all the
way to the left oh is that fresh lime
juice fresh lime
the juice from the golden tiki here and
we'll do
three fourths of an ounce of
that okay give it back to the next next
we're gonna go
pina
the pineapple juice oh i love it i see
the pulp in there yeah everything get up
you get nothing but the best yes yes so
this we have one ounce and uh love
pineapple pineapple just screams
tropical and it has sweetness but it
also has a little bit of acidity to it
yeah a little tartness okay so much is
this did you set this up for me
perfectly or what right in mind is next
this is allspice dram okay what's that
allspice strand is a jamaican liqueur oh
that is um it has all spice berry and
loads of different spice elements um
blended with pot still rum so it has a
little bit of funkiness a little bit
spicy is that something that's typically
used as a mixer or is that something
that you just drink straight away you
know you could drink it on the rocks um
but it's definitely great as a modifier
okay a modifier i like that yes okay all
right so think of it as a cocktail
seasoning yeah add like a quarter ounce
it's like salt and pepper i love it i'm
learning so much this is fantastic okay
just a little bit just a little bit this
one's a quarter ounce okay now boom now
we're actually going to skip the line
we're going to go to
oh right in the front this one right
here that one what is this that is a
velvet flairnum
okay you're gonna have to explain that
one to me falerinum is not just fun to
say it's delicious okay so traditionally
it is a rum-based liqueur from barbados
oh but our friends that dress the drink
i've helped them make this and uh along
with james manos and cindy over there
the amazing people but they make
delicious things so you guys are so
innovative in your cocktails that's one
of my favorite things about you that's
that's amazing and this brings like
ginger and citrus and all kinds of
wonderful flavors okay i'm gonna do a
quarter ounce in there as well to round
it out all right what else
so next oh it's right here i'll grab it
that looks like a secret potion there
secret potions that's what you come to
the gold tiki for
secret potions and full of love for real
you're it is a secret potion no this is
uh
sort of
bees made it which um i don't know how
they make it exactly scientists will
tell you all right this is a honey syrup
gotcha gotcha
okay i'm excited this is like the most
intricate cocktail ever
and there's oh wait there's more okay so
and we still have so now we will do a
little bit of mescal okay i'll let you
have you had mezcal before i have very
smoky i like it yeah
that's good and this is one thing that
if you add too much it can easily take
over a cocktail okay and this one it'll
add nice little accent flavor and a
little nuance to it so you're not
putting in a full shot or just a little
tiny just a little quarter ounce oh okay
all right
and then and then we're going to go to
tequila do we use two different tequilas
on this one two different textures oh my
gosh okay so do you want the dark one
which one is this this one is almond
agave and the owners actually live here
local las vegas it's made in uh in
tequila or in in haliskoda um it's all
there agave is grown by lake chapala
which has like a really interesting
climate
which gives a high bricks level on the
agave and makes for a really unique
wonderful tequila okay i'm gonna go
half an ounce of this i like that you're
not um over you know overdoing it it's
just a little bit i know we have one
minute left i want to make sure we get
this all beautiful done because i'm
dying
okay so next we have an ounce and a half
of this
and that is kind of like
the power the majority of the spirit in
there so i'm going to give it a little
bit of a whip shake whip shake is just
adding a little bit of
pellet ice just to aerate it okay we're
not really diluting at this point we're
just aerating and incorporating the
flavors
and the moves yes
i like it and you frost it up it looks
nice oh wow it froths right up so i'm
just going to pour it right into this
cold glass and then i'm going to douse
it with
a good amount of this pellet ice to get
it to
a very cold temperature and you're very
particular about your ice i overheard
you earlier saying that you guys have
your own ice that you use
yes this pellet ice really you know we
we some people will say oh there's too
much ice in it but we actually say it's
very important for the integrity of the
cocktail and the enjoyment of the
cocktail oh okay and this is this is
where the beauty comes into it so here's
a little dehydrated pineapple also made
by our friends address the drink
and then a little pineapple frond and
then let's just throw
some luxardo cherries in there and you
can get this at the golden tiki this is
actually a true work of art i don't want
to drink it it's too pretty can i drink
it dive in i mean he's going to make it
for you you don't have to worry about
making it yourself let's take
oh my goodness wow that is fantastic
you're the best go check them out golden
tiki helping the community all the time
thank you so much thank you jillian over
to you
well if you are hosting